we go tonight you've been the alpha for
so long Willa it's hard to imagine you
letting go of the position without a
fight but luckily you didn't have to
step down as number one you had your
doubts about Addison from the start but
she proved you wrong in the right kind
of way you might come off as mean and
tough but Willa your bark is worse than
your bite we hope to see more of you in
zombies three if that ever happens
perfect
zombies - had a fresh storyline an
amazing soundtrack and a pack of new and
wild characters the Disney Channel
sequel had it all movie mistakes
included we have ten mistakes from
zombies - lined up for you but before we
start we like to point out that this
video contains some major spoilers so
keep watching at your discretion if
you're all up to date watch until the
end to find out which huge mistake
disproves the alpha wolf legend when we
first meet Addison and zombies she's
ashamed of her natural hair color
causing her to cover it up with a wig
but by the end of the film she's ready
to come clean about her hair color so
she takes off her wig that's when we see
that Addison's hair is collarbone length
however come zombies - Addison's hair
seems to have grown three times as fast
as it should have
zombies - picks up at Seabrook high
after a groundbreaking semester so
basically only a semester has passed
since we first saw is that and Addison
fall in love on the small screen but if
that's the case how did Addison's hair
grow so quickly according to health line
hair grows an average of six inches
every year but Addison's grew over six
inches in just under three months since
Addison's hair is very different than
everyone else's it may grow at a faster
rate however this was never explained
and it's being seen as a continuity
error when the town of Seabrook finds
out that werewolves are real they panic
and choose to restore the monster law
half of the town is put under curfew
while the other residents are too afraid
to leave their house Willa and her pack
choose to sneak their way into Seabrook
High where they can locate the
white-haired alpha in the morning but to
do this they have to keep a low pro
file or else they risk getting caught
the pack dances their way into Seabrook
high where they take refuge and events
great office near but this scene had a
few mistakes that didn't go unnoticed by
eagle-eye fans first of all how did
Willa Wyatt winter and the pack get into
the school last time we checked schools
were locked at night especially during
monster curfews and most curiously how
did the entire pack managed to fit
behind an air vent in the hallway seeing
the Wolves walk into the vent was like
watching clowns casually stroll out of a
clown car focus fierce
midway through zombies - Zed catches
Wyatt and Addison sharing a special
moment which leads him to say things he
doesn't mean
according to Zed werewolves they're not
interested in fitting and according to
Addison the Zed is trying to fit him so
badly he's forgetting who he truly is
Zed lashes out on Addison says the girl
who wore a wig her whole life this leads
to a heartfelt duet called gotta find
where I belong which is sung by Zed
Madison who have just fought for the
first time but something a little
strange happens during this duet we see
Addison walking through a hallway
wearing her cheerleader uniform but
seconds later when she turns to corner
and walks out of school she's wearing a
light blue outfit instead while it's
normal for outfit changes to occur the
song seemed to be unfolding in real time
causing viewers to raise an eyebrow or
two at Addison spontaneous new outfit we
spotted more than one mistaken gotta
find where I belong but more on that
later come with us
what's so important it's a well-known
fact that werewolves and silver don't
mix however there are a few
inconsistencies surrounding this ancient
fact in zombies - while walking through
the Seabrook High trophy Hall willow
winter and Wyatt reveal that wolves
aren't scared of anything silver but
then you can see a werewolf in the
background grab hold of a silver trophy
and start screaming when it burns his
hands this doesn't sound like something
a scared werewolf er do so we figured
that Disney wanted viewers to know just
how detrimental silver could be to
werewolves problem is near the end of
the film the wolves are handcuffed to
have to bring sprayed with a thick veil
of silver smoke Dale reveals that he
sprayed them with collodial silver and
claims that it will tame them which it
does
here's the problem why didn't the silver
smoke burn the wolves like the trophy
did being sprayed by a liquid with
silver attribute should have given the
Wolves some serious burns but it never
did if it's gonna hurt the werewolves
you have to stop it you're right
when we first reunite with Zed in
Addison they revealed that Seabrook and
zombie town have united forces to create
a brand new civilization however
everything falls apart when it's
announced that werewolves are on the
loose
zebra chooses to reinstate the monster
law preventing zombies from going to
pron and upholding their human rights
but wait did anyone else think it was
strange that Willa and her pack were
accepted into Seabrook High with open
arms
despite the monster law still being in
effect this is not about politics I
always just felt like she could unite we
mean the whole reason the monster law
was reinstated in the first place was
because werewolves were in town and yet
they were allowed to join the school no
questions asked it just doesn't add up
what's even weirder is that principal
Lee didn't even get a choice in the
matter
Addison and coach decided to welcome the
wolves without ever consulting her how
could monsters join the local high
school when the monster law was in full
swing can you explain this movie mistake
sound off in the comments Brie's
Addison's best friend and she has a huge
crush on Bonzo who likes her back
problem is a Bonzo doesn't seem to speak
English
whereas Bree shouldn't be able to
understand a word coming out of Bonzo's
mouth but as it turns out Bonzo and Bree
have no problem communicating during
zombies - Zed suggests that seabrooke
high teach the students how to speak
zombie it's Amitabha second language
good so we know that it's not on the
curriculum so how does Bree understand
the zombie language she could have
learned how to speak zombie on her own
since she does have a crush on Bonzo but
how did she master the language so
quickly when Bonzo asks Bree to attend
the prom with him she says yes without
missing a beat did anyone else find this
strange keep watching for the biggest
mistake in zombies - Addison Zed and the
wolf's go to extreme lengths to save the
moonstone from being destroyed in the
power plant explosion
sadly the seabrooke power plant
accidentally explodes after they win the
fight the wolves
are immediately affected and many of
them fall ill when Zed visits the Wolves
hideout he sees firsthand how the
explosion is affecting them many of them
are so sick they can't even stand they
were wrong to destroy zebra power but
this rule doesn't apply to Willa and
Wyatt
despite their powers coming from the
same energy source Willa and Wyatt are
seen standing upright and helping their
pack mates still they decide to go to
prawn and have a good time this plot
hole isn't super obvious but the more we
think about it the less it makes sense
wouldn't Willa and Wyatt be just as sick
as the other wolf's and why would Willa
who has seen as the alpha leave her pack
behind when they need her the most
earlier on in this video we mentioned
that there was two mistakes in the duet
gotta find where I belong the first one
revolves around Addison spontaneous
outfit change and the second one takes
place near the end of the song when day
turns to night in the blink of an eye
Addison start singing the two-minute
song while she's still at school but by
the time the song comes to an end it's
dark outside could it be that Zed and
Addison's duet defies the hands of time
like their relationship defies social
standards even one protesting for what's
right it sure seems like it
or perhaps time isn't as linear in
Seabrook as it is in real life this
could explain the time jump that takes
place and it gotta find where I belong
as well as the mystery behind Addison's
hair growth one of the biggest mistakes
in zombies - revolves around the magical
moonstone throughout the sequel willow
reveals that without the moonstone
werewolf's will stop existing however
when the moonstone is destroyed in the
power plant explosion the werewolves
fall ill instead of disappearing but the
biggest mistake of all is exposed when
the moonstone reveals itself to Addison
and the Wolves midway through pron the
students find out that the moonstone has
not been destroyed
the wolves are then able to recharge
their crystals and cure themselves but
if the moonstone was never destroyed in
the first place why did all the wolves
get sick at the exact same time it could
be that the placebo effect came into
play the Wolves thought the moonstone
had been destroyed so their bodies
tricked them into feeling sick what do
you guys think was this a major plot
hole or not zombies 2 was amazing but
there's a one last mistake that we just
can't shake and it has everything to do
with the legend of the great alpha ever
since the Wolves saw Addison's white
hair at the beginning of the movie they
believed her to be the great alpha you
are a leader Addison but if something a
lot greater than sheer according to them
there's a prophecy that states that an
alpha werewolf will lead the wolves to
the moon stone however when Addison
finally tries on the werewolf necklace
it doesn't light up for her so basically
she's not a werewolf still she is the
one who led the wolves to the moon stone
so if Addison isn't the alpha wolf
there's a huge mistake surrounding the
legend of the great alpha I thought
everything would make sense if I was a
werewolf could it be that Addison really
is a werewolf but that zedzee van
supercharged her necklace preventing it
from lighting up or could the prophecy
be wrong sound off in the comments and
be sure to tell us if you spotted any
more mistakes in zombies 2 they think
we're monsters we are monsters give this
video a big thumbs up and don't forget
to subscribe to the things for more
we'll see you next time thanks for
watching
you